[Music]
okay welcome
to off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
today we got i mean dude we got the boys
come on let's go today
is a special day because we have so many
guests
that are actually regulars now like
anthony
except for me and bart everyone here was
once a guest who used to sit there
and now even you steve look at you you
used to sit there and
now you're like the host with the most
of my way in and you got to tear a hat
and a t-shirt bro you got a wrap you got
it
i i wasn't going to wear it today
because crypto's down and stuff
yeah criminals yeah
and your face 40 went to 40 i was like
okay we back
back there was no sweat the whole time
by the way
yeah at 29. right you should have bought
at 29 huh
you should have bought it 29. you know
what is back though that is kind of like
i hate it but i
like i don't like it it's la oh true
yeah because like well the mass and
everything and now we can like
everything's basically [ __ ] open
right but then
so are the freeways but you think you
think about you think all the
restaurants
that like yes had to go through struggle
and then suddenly like got a bunch of
like parking spaces to have as real
estate for their tables and then
and then they got to open bags now they
just have double real estate
that's pretty smart a bunch of
restaurants just came to freak up right
yeah like little tokyo they're serving
dining tables in the middle of the
street yeah it's cool but like it's not
like they're gonna take that away right
because that's like gotta go into just
open air should why why are we not been
open air
this whole day like paris like paris i
like paris yeah but you guys
you guys know that when we walk by
restaurants that aren't really populated
we're kind of like oh nobody's going
here
right should i and that's kind of what
this does like you just see emptiness
outside i'm always like
oh i used to like this place
i also feel bad when i go in the
restaurant not without a mask right
and i'm like oh you still gotta wear one
because you work here i know
yeah you do feel bad tango when you walk
in the door you're like
like you're like you like doing it
the workers yeah the servers they still
wear them yeah i think it went for a
while i don't know
it makes me feel good actually it's not
bad because you worry about
you know people preparing your food and
all kinds of stuff you worry they're
gonna spit
your food or something gonna happen like
they're gonna mask they could spit like
this
they could but you know when they're
talking to each other there's a little
piece flies out yeah
that's gone that's i like that you think
if they sneeze in their masks
your food's completely prepared i mean
it's not completely funny
you've seen the videos not completely
but at least a little bit
no i understand the fact that they can
breathe through it is indication enough
where you're like oh [ __ ]
i should i wish i could i'm glad i can't
see it have you guys been to the dim sum
restaurant on atlantic the upstairs yeah
they have this
clear acrylic cough guard right and i
saw this lady with a dim sum car
too and went and i'm like thank god she
was out
but now you just see it this was like
2016 2017.
they're
it was just normal a chew and then she's
just like you want some
i think people stop the scissors you
aren't caught
no i'm good we're open we're good i'll
just hang out my homies from
they just moved from the philippines and
they just moved here like
last month but they said dude the
philippines is still locked down
15 000 plus every day they said they
can't go out in the streets
the streets are locked down so in here
they're building they can't walk their
building without a pvp pv
pipe suit the whole suit what what
looking like breaking bad and [ __ ] yeah
and you can't be in the streets
without not just a mask full-on glass
shield wow
and there's like they're like shut down
apm for you but like you can't be on the
streets without a whole suit on in a
mask in like
in like major cities right now in manila
in the
capital i just saw something about how
the philippines is giving out
guns because they want to combat crime
that's cool
that's cool that is the most gangster
[ __ ] i've ever heard yeah that guy does
not know
he's under investigation right now
because it's like
it was yeah he's out there i'm cool
yeah me too i love him he got a [ __ ]
wife
if you see us in manila we cool but yeah
that's crazy over there
get shot for smoking like it's it it's a
law like if anyone's doing
drugs and you see them like any person
can shoot them
holy [ __ ] they're like
he's shooting i'm like do you want to
get blown away my daddy would have had
weed on them
if i had rivals i would just throw
joints at him and be like catch
boom low-key that's kind of what some
people were saying what's happening
that's the [ __ ] like the wild wild
west because before he even lets go
if i was the rival as soon as he passed
it i'm [ __ ] shooting him
because his goal is to throw it on me
it's just both this is in the air we're
both treating each other
he was serious about the war on drugs
you set war on drugs
go to the philippines this is for real
war on drugs you're in the philippines
and you're like man drugs used to be so
fun
what happened to drugs man i know don't
have a rave in the philippines right
it's going to be a massacre
it's not a massive low key there's still
drugs all around just saying people are
like
you get shot for it that's crazy by just
like anybody not even like
authority just like everyone has the
authority but my friend everyone got the
authority to shoot if they see some
drugs
but my friend was saying like how since
duarte is in power
they're like thank god because my real
estate is stable now
there's like less corruption and um i
can sell my properties
or like i guess before that there was a
lot of corruption
i don't know i don't know i mean like i
don't know enough about politics don't
be canceling me over you guys on this
philippine party's back
i don't think well we're not critical of
georgia anyway we love the guy no i
don't you know i don't know
it's what the philippines needs i think
i think when americans criticize it's
really jealousy oh yeah because i mean
what that's so cool imagine being the
dude and you're just like
hey um my cops can't handle this problem
man so i call upon the powers of my
citizens to blast these drug dealers
it's like low-key people are always
saying he's the one
again i'm getting trouble but i don't
know this story right here his son's
like the biggest drug dealer in the
philippines he's trying to
cut all the competition for his family
it's a ruse
it's the room this is like full-on i
always feel like this could be a real
good netflix show it's like game of
thrones
yeah yeah it's like so many story lines
except for you know they they don't mess
around
they will come get you we just can't
shoot it over there now i know there's a
thing like
did you guys know back in the day have
you ever heard of the uh american me
murders oh after the movie came out
right movie oh wait there was a murder
that came
after hella murdered the mexican mafia
what about the asian guy that was like
[ __ ] look open your eyes that's it
open your eyes
open your eyes they say yeah but i think
the mexican mafia came out and they said
they didn't like
how some of the things were portrayed
and they just started wiping out some
casting crew members yeah
producers yeah that's crazy like you're
done you're done you're done we're like
i don't like how his cortez is we're not
from nineteen no
if you watch the movie because they
because they they're raping guys and
pretty like they were showing the real
stuff right they were hardly produced
back then
with that yeah what happened was i think
when i remember what's up well i was
still in like high school or something
and
and i come i was i grew up in paramount
right so i was like mexican neighborhood
and when it was coming out we all were
like i was like
mexican godfather and it is to a degree
but they went raw
super raw juvi like gangster ass i think
they wanted to show like they want to
show like the ugliness of it yeah yeah
but i think my dude what's his name
deleting it
it wasn't ray liotta right was that that
was colors or not lou diamond phillips
but
the other guy almost james james almost
james
oh yes he's still got security because
probably still after his ass why because
he was just he's just
oh he was a good like protagonist he was
great i mean i do like
a teacher too i still like that movie a
lot because remember they had like the
asian dead character tagawa
and they had the white dude too that was
like hanging out with the mexicans he
was dope yeah
and what all the asian guy did was open
your eyes they said it was so funny
it was one of the funniest scenes ever
little puppet open your eyes
i i didn't see this movie what was the
premise of it american me it's
it's it's a story of like the mexican
gangs in southern california it's like a
mexican gang called
classic there's that and there's like
blood and blood out blood and blood out
i think it was just showcasing a story
of like
how the gangs came to be how they needed
to protect themselves and then once they
got into like the prison system
[ __ ] up it is once you get to prison
yeah and then how there's like the the
races are segregated and then you see
like how you have to kind of audition
like there's one part where
um he tells him like we need to kill
that guy and then he gives it to the
youngest
the new youngest member and then the
older brother steps no no
i'll do it i'll do it he goes nah he has
to do it just that kind of like
like kind of like showing like the
reality joe i think but once it got to
the rape
you know because it they should like how
whatever like the i
don't i never been i've never been to
prison but the dominance thing like they
just dominating each other let them know
like
i'm your you know you're my [ __ ] but no
one really wants to see that about their
culture
like no one wants to see that like can
we allude to that
it happens in prison i'm sure it does
that's why none of us want to go to
prison
yeah but they didn't have it in the in
the in the [ __ ]
they didn't have any like good fellas or
like they didn't have it in like yeah
you know like but it did
they glamorize that [ __ ] though you know
i don't think it was glamorized they
were like trying to show
how [ __ ] up it is it was pretty
glamorous it wasn't glass
raped a prisoner you know no no i'm
saying they didn't show it in
good fellas right it was more like
american me and and like um
american history x like things like that
it's like a dark side
of gang life right but then like all the
scorsese films made me want to be
an italian gangster yeah i see that they
he had a different feel on it
they should have went glamorization but
they went with see that's probably
what they don't like today's video is
brought to you by warby parker
and worry park is awesome because
they're dedicated to providing
exceptional
eye care to you at their store or at
home
and they cover everything from
eyeglasses to sunglasses
eye exams and even contact lenses
and some other glasses start at 95 bucks
with the lenses so they have this real
cool home try on kit
that they send completely for free right
so you go ahead
and you take this quiz and then they
know what kind of stuff that you might
want
and you go ahead and you pick five
glasses from glasses to sunglasses
i personally picked five sunglasses
because i just wanted to look cool and i
was gonna go to hawaii and
i just tried it on and i was like yo i
like all five i don't know what i'm
gonna do
and then i decided you know i have my
two most
favorite one and i sent it back
and then i got two brand new ones that i
chose it was pretty cool
that is really cool so a lot of people
love orbeez particles they don't gotta
go in the store
so right now you can try the warby
parker try at home kit for free
you order five glasses they ship it to
you for free you get to try them on see
which ones you like
and they even give you the return
shipping for free
so make sure to warbyparker.com off the
record to try on
five glasses for free that's
warbyparker.com
off the record that makes us make you
think we got to go to prison like where
are we going to go you can go to
mexicans no you got to go to asia we
have our own area how big is our asian
clique you know they they have a they
have an asian unit i want to go with the
brokers dude
put me in with the [ __ ] broker i know
the federal white collar
crime where did martha stewart go i want
to go with her
yeah i want to get my tennis game up i'm
going to the library either that or the
drag cleaning department i know
i always feel like if i get busted doing
something can you i just do my time
like do y'all just want to have to rape
me and beat me up and [ __ ] i mean we're
already here
i gotta be here for 10 years is this
your reasoning with rapists
i picture dante in his block you know
how like they have scheduled days
it's like 7am and the thing goes cook
and it opens up
a guy with a heart on is walking up to
dante and he pulls this like
hey do we all do we have to do this [ __ ]
like do we really have to do this
like he's running for asb student
president he's like
we got to get these speeches and do all
this [ __ ] we're better than this
get that thing down or go next door yeah
not about this life can i just do my
damn
time i'm just always curious how they
initiate it
like how do dudes like this
i dude it's happening and they start
taking their clothes off i watch prison
breaks but it's very similar very
similar they just
start caressing one of my boys went to
president said hey man this is the thing
when you get to prison you got to just
fight whoever wants to fight you matter
of fact go to the person you think you
could be
and just beat him up as quickly as
possible i was like that's crazy that's
a real thing you know like you go up to
the dude and you just beat the [ __ ] out
like
who's can i get because even if you lose
you better like you better have your
speech ready
why don't you pick the smallest guy
that's like a [ __ ] black belt killer
and [ __ ]
former navy seal and [ __ ] and you're
like oh i picked the wrong guy
and then you're like oh [ __ ] me man and
he's gay
yeah oh no yeah and then after he's like
i want your booty now
you're like i picked the wrong dude
i picked the wrong guy dude the stakes
on mma
would be so much higher if the winner
got to [ __ ] the guy
i've been saying this for years i've
been saying this for years did you
really talk that much [ __ ] before the
fight or would you be like
hey man how you doing dude good to see
you man like it would be so much
different think about how much better
the fights would be
because they're fighting the fight's
already great the fights are already
amazing yeah
but now with the stipulation is you get
[ __ ] by the winner and they take
viagra 30 minutes before that oh my god
so you're hard during the fight oh
that only works if you're straight
because if you
if you if you're a fan and you're gay
and you're just like
i can't wait to get with connor yeah and
they're like oh no i'm losing
i'm losing we're all [ __ ] losing
where's your coach
just be like a uh you know agreed upon
federation size like dildo
or something like that i mean you have
to set the rules
um kind of like savages around there's a
spalding nba basketball right
this is a regulation basketball we all
play with we're not we're not animals
bro yeah we have the standard dildo size
for everybody you're just gonna get
yeah compromise after the fight but then
there's different if you lose you're
gonna get
compromised compromise is a good word
yeah and it goes on like
and it goes on like pornhub for like
ever that's what's at stake here
yeah and then you get to eat steak
afterwards
conor mcgregor fully compromised i can
see it i'm clicking that there's like a
pay-per-view separate for that
come back the next five like i'm not
about that i'm about to [ __ ] whoever
comes in this ring
up for real the big question is after
the fight is over do they have a
ceremony
to the the [ __ ] or they just go right
into it
it's like it's like the [ __ ] happens
and then the podium happens and then on
the podium you can see like the
fragments of their experience
there you go and then joe rogan
interviews them twice
the second time hey let's look at the
tape here uh how'd you feel right in
that moment
i mean uh didn't feel great i mean i
thought i'm
thinking about different things about
the fight now but
incredible job he got [ __ ] up and
[ __ ] in
oh my god yeah i think he's a good
friend that does dana white
that just reminds me of some old spartan
[ __ ] some gladiator [ __ ]
yeah cause they were gay as hell right
like they they loved each other like
literally
so then um they did yes alexander bro
yeah i think that's part why they're so
gangsters just like you
they're gangsters why there was i don't
know
i think parvo was like you know you
fighting for your loved one but you like
fighting
the shield right like the person that
you're protecting to that's your lover
usually
you know they raise the the spartan
children um up until the age of i think
30 like that was like when they
were like full grown men but um they
basically
take them they turn them into orphans
right like once you're a kid
uh remember in the movie like they would
check if you're healthy or whatever then
i throw away the shitty ones right
yeah [ __ ] is a good word and then it's
[ __ ]
wild dude so when you're young um you
don't live at home with your parents
you live in like barracks and [ __ ] and
then the only way you can kind of eat is
go off and steal [ __ ]
and then for your graduation you have to
kill one of the
uh slaves or servants like just that
working
doing picking fruit or whatever you just
go in there and you [ __ ] kill them
they just made them like
straight serial killers they're social
fascists
highly encouraged the the boys to fall
in love with each other
so then when you love your uh partner
like crazy right
you're gonna defend them like crazy so
they psychologically put these guys
and turned them into crazy warriors that
culture didn't last that long huh that's
also distracting though because then
you're show up on the battlefield
sure like bite your lip all the time
yeah you're like where's bobby and andy
they we didn't even all they're [ __ ]
in the box
you're like going through war [ __ ]
you're like stop making out [ __ ]
i mean 300 was a dope movie but then
you're like these dudes are going to war
in like
speedos and capes what the [ __ ]
they should redo 300 with that
perspective like the real one dude
it's in there somewhere i'm talking
about making porn dude
you're like they should do a 300 porn
that's only been the war but if i go to
war i'm wearing more than a [ __ ]
speed on a cape
first i want more armor like you got a
big-ass shield i need some [ __ ]
i don't need just to speed on the cape
ain't [ __ ] perfect and isn't it
europe cold
cold as [ __ ] you got leather sandals on
and a speedo or you have more mobility
in your arms and [ __ ] like you don't
you're not bogged down by all this armor
the other thing is that
whole isn't enough for me but they're
also used to being nude like living like
a straight animal
because they get like one loincloth for
like 10 years or some [ __ ] and that's
all you gotta [ __ ] wear i guess
you're an animal if you're like i'm an
animal
but what about it's also mediterranean
climate what about the cape i don't know
if the cape is accurate bro
i don't even know that like we're not
gonna wear any armor but we need a cape
dude they had them in alexander that's
gotta be
all those caves the whole era of cape
[ __ ] is like why what the [ __ ]
who's that thought we needed cakes i
hope if a fashion thing
cycles in like when you go straight to
caves you know why they cycle out though
it's because every time a guy shows up
in a cave like what the [ __ ] are you
wearing man
he's like oh yeah true sorry all you
gotta do is put a [ __ ] hood on it and
now it's a cloak and everybody's cool
with it all right
cool with it that's worse how many
clothes you got your closet like two
it's a clone i think you could pull it
off though you do like
the hair but never one specifically a
jedi cloak like star wars branded that's
dope
that's dope but maybe because we live in
that that's dope i'm with that what
would you but
but where but also i think like star
wars came out in the 70s where
when capes were back in you know like
you see all those like disco guys with
capes
so that's when star wars came out so all
of a sudden that's why they had the
capes and star wars well that's what i'm
saying
i'm just saying capes need to come back
have you seen a mongolian hunter though
yeah you first have you seen the
mongolian falcon hunter
those schools were capes like the ones
from mulan bro no like
they also wear falcons though they have
falcons on their shoulder what a [ __ ]
it's like misdirection you're like still
looking like oiggers to bet and they got
those they hunt
with the hawk yeah but they have capes
man made out of like
[ __ ] coyotes that they caught but
they're cold though bro
in a cape cape the cape's not it bro no
i could be dope i mean because you could
wear anything under the cape
right i think cape and like [ __ ]
royal
cloaks from like ancient times are like
different you know what i'm saying
they have to be functional i think it's
like cape i think of like you know
attached by velcro on two hinges of your
shoulders that provide no function
you know what i'm saying or like
superman other than other than showing
the fact that there's wind turbulence
you know the tape is just an accessory
for speed yeah whereas like cloak
suddenly can become you know when you
when you walk on regal and [ __ ] hide
i got three ponchos that's a mexican
cloak that's the mexican coke
dude nobody's more pissed though than
the guys on hollywood highland who like
the new hot show was game of thrones and
now they got a weird game of thrones
[ __ ] out there
in the middle of the summer and they're
like son of a [ __ ] winter's coming
guys
dying if he's stroking [ __ ] why can't
popular shows be like baywatch anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you